I think we're good to go. Can folks hear me? Yes? I can hear myself. Good.
So I'd like to welcome everyone to the NCI session this
afternoon on drug development resources and grant writing strategies for new
and early stage investigators. My name is Rose Orojema.
I am the associate director of the Developmental Therapeutics Program
within the
Division of Cancer Treatment and Diagnosis at the National Cancer Institute.
And I and my colleagues will be covering a number of topics
for you today,
and we're very grateful to be here since we missed AACR last year.
I have no
financial relationships because I work for the government.
So we're going to talk about drug development resources.
I'll be covering that, and then my colleagues will be talking about navigating the
grant application processes,
grant funding mechanisms and opportunities, grant writing tips, updates to the
application review process, as you know, this is a very dynamic area right now,
and Q&A.
So, my deputy actually prepared these slides, but he wasn't able to travel
here. So Christophe Marchand is the deputy in our Developmental
Therapeutics Program.
I don't think this is the right slide deck.
I deleted that slide. It's okay. I can deal with it. It's fine.
Is it the one-
It's fine
... which is April 19th?
Yeah. All right. It's fine. So the one thing
that's most important to remember about the Developmental Therapeutics Program is
that you should try to find this landing page on the internet.
The address is dtp.cancer.gov, and there you will
find a whole list of different kinds of
avenues to get support for your drug discovery and development
program.
Among those are things like the NCI60 high throughput
screen that we run for free for investigators.
Investigators will apply online to submit their compounds,
and we will run them in our screen, which is the
NCI60 cancer cell panel,
and then the data is uploaded and available to the scientists
who submitted the compounds. And you can see not only a GI50, but
also you can use the compare analysis algorithm, which is a
way to help define what target pathway your particular
compound may be
targeting.
We also have a drug development consultation service that we provide to
all
outside innovators, private, public, academic.
It's confidential. We only have federal staff who are bound by confidentiality
laws who participate in the consultation.
And it's a good way to assess the critical path of your drug development plan.
We have our toxicologists and pharmacologists and chemists and
biologists all participating in this consultation.
And we can review with you what you are trying to develop, and we
will help you understand the risks, the kinds of data that you will
need either to apply to NCI for funding or support,
or even to talk to the FDA about your
proposed clinical trial.
And it's not just for small molecules, it's also for biologics, it's for
imaging agents, it's for nanotechnology products.
And we can give you advice on all sorts of aspects of development.
So
importantly, we support the outside community
through a variety of different mechanisms.
In this arrow on the bottom, you can see that basic research is
actually outside of our scope. It is covered by the Division of Cancer
Biology at NCI. We,
in the Development of Therapeutics Program, work within the preclinical research
arena from discovery up until
IND-enabling activities to get a drug into a clinical trial.
And Morgan O'Hare is here. She's going to talk about the Stepping Stones program
later on. But you can see the different kinds of support that we will offer
for the drug development
enterprise. We can do GLP studies.
We can do GMP manufacturing,
not just small molecules, but also biologics.
And I'll talk a little bit about that in a moment.
And we do screening, and
especially we have a large natural products library that I'll talk about.
The tumor repository, as it suggests holds a
very large collection of mouse and human tumors.
But most notably, we have the patient-derived tumor repository, which
is a really large collection of
freshly collected tumors from patients that were developed
into either PDCs, which are patient-derived cell lines,
PDOs, PD orgs, which are patient-derived organoids,
or PDXs, which are the tissue fragments that
we have expanded in mice,
that we can provide to investigators to do their own research.
We also have cancer-associated fibroblasts to match
some of those models as well.
We have a chemical agents repository that has a large collection of compounds,
along with NCI60 data available on those compounds, and
those are available. We also have plated sets that are of use
to discovery researchers.
The natural product repository is a very large collection of plated,
pre-fractionated natural extracts,
and we actually have, right now, over 75 active
collaborations with outside
investigators who are screening those plated sets in order to look
for active compounds against not just cancer, but also infectious diseases
and other
clinical indications.And in addition to providing the plated
sets, once an investigator finds a hit in that plated set,
our chemists will work with the investigator to try to identify the active compound
within that pre-fractionated sample.
And each pre-fractionated sample in the plate has about 10 to
compounds in it. So the chemist will work diligently to try to
separate out the active compound, provide it back to the investigator to test, and
in the end, hopefully find a new
active compound that can be used then for a drug development
medicinal chemistry program.
We also have a biologics reagent repository that has a number of
monoclonal antibodies, cytokines, and other growth factors.
We have the biopharmaceutical development program.
This is actually a manufacturing facility in Frederick, Maryland,
where we manufacture all sorts of biopharmaceuticals.
We can make monoclonal antibodies.
We can make recombinant proteins.
We have also provided things like peptides and ADCs.
And most recently, we have developed, over the past several years,
the capability to produce cell therapies, CAR T cells.
We have a number of GMP suites where we do this manufacturing, and
we actually have a network that we are funding where these products are being used
in clinical trials around the country.
We have most recently developed CRISPR-based gene editing for
non-viral cell therapy.
And as you can see in the graphic on the bottom right, we will
receive patient apheresis material, we will make the CAR T product, and then we
will ship it back to the clinical site for
delivery to the patient.
And now I'm going to hand this over to Morgan O'Hare, and she's going to talk some
more about some of the resources that we provide.
Thank you. I'm going to go into a little bit more detail on the Stepping
Stones program and consultation service that Rose introduced, as well as
talk about the NCI Experimental Therapeutics program.
I also have no relationships to disclose.
So the Stepping Stones program is
to support our active NCI-funded
grantees'
advanced therapeutics
towards the clinic. And so we recognize that grants don't always
include some of the routine or iterative tasks that are really
important for advancing a compound or getting venture capital,
NExT funding, SBIR funding, whatever that may be.
And so our goal is to help kind of bridge that gap, and by
providing data
stepping stones, we call them, so basically filling some data gaps through
contract resources and in-house resources that we have.
So the types of activities that we support through Stepping
Stones include limited toxicology, PK studies,
PD, synthetic route optimization,
limited formulation work, and so these really are kind of limited
and gap-filling activities. But our goal is really to take
advantage of our grant portfolio and help advance
those compounds through the valley of death so that they can get
to IND eventually or
de-risk them early on before there's a lot more investment through
venture capital or SBIR or the NExT program.
So we recognize, as I mentioned earlier, that not all
labs or institutions have a full range of drug development
resources.
And so,
by providing this service, we can use contracts and get really
high-quality data for investigators,
as long as it's not already part of your grant.
We don't double fund things, or if it's funded through something else, we can't
support it. But,
we can support activities that will help
advance the molecule that aren't already funded.
These are limited to NCI grants for Stepping
Stone support that have already gone through peer review and vetting.
They're also, right now, our focus is on lead
small molecules. So,
unfortunately, right now we don't have the budget or scope for
biologics. But for small molecule candidates, we can
use Stepping Stone resources to help advance them.
And it is a small investment. It's not meant to span the whole
IND enabling scope. That will be done by another program called
NExT that I'll talk about. And
we're hoping that by filling in these data gaps, we can improve
chances for gaining those more complete
resources like NExT, venture capital, or SBIR.
So, the types of projects that we have supported
include doing some formulation work, including salt
screens, developing oral suspensions for
gavage. We've optimized synthetic route,
conducted scale-up. We've conducted PK studies in
mouse and rat rodent models.
We've done ADME and DMPK studies for metabolic
stability,
CYP profiling, HERG
transporters,
and also connected to biomarker
resources at NCI for pharmacodynamic assays.
And upon receiving Stepping Stone support, several PIs have
successfully applied for SBIR and STTR
funding. Others have kind of gone back to the drawing board and
realized maybe the PK is not optimal and tried to optimize their
chemistry a little more. And others have
moved their compounds forward with startup companies or venture
capital.So the entry points
for Stepping Stones, as I mentioned,
these have to be NCI-funded grants.
Our focus is on small molecules at this time, and not
just
hits or chemical probes, but really focusing
on lead molecules that you're intending to advance
toward IND.
And so we start with a consultation and look
at where the progress is and where there may be data gaps.
And your program director for your grant would be actively
involved in this process as well.
So just a summary of some of the projects we've supported so far.
We've had six rounds, supported 17 projects,
covering a wide variety of malignancies and conditions.
So most are targeting tumors, but we also
supported a project for treatment of
chemotherapy-induced peripheral neuropathy.
So it's not always just anti-cancer, but also
therapy-related toxicities we're interested as well.
And you can see we've also supported these projects across the
country.
So our on-ramp for Stepping Stones starts with a
consultation service, but as Rose introduced earlier,
this really is a broad service that's open to anybody.
You don't have to be a grantee. You don't have to be in academia.
This is really open to all investigators.
It is confidential,
so we do keep everything just within our group.
And our goal with the consultation service is to assess the path
for product development and give guidance on where your gaps may be
if you're intending to move forward or try and seek alternative
funding.
We have a wide variety of expertise on the call, and unlike Stepping
Stones, this program really covers
for small molecules, for biologics, imaging agents,
nanotherapeutics, radiopharmaceuticals.
So there's really quite a range of what we can provide guidance and
advice on.
We've had this consultation service for about seven years.
We've had over 300 consultations with investigators
during that time, as you can see, across the country as well as
internationally, and for small molecules, biologics,
and imaging agents.
So I wanted to touch, I've alluded to this NCI Experimental Therapeutics
Program a couple times. This is really a full
development
for drug discovery and development, a full program.
It provides resources kind of like Stepping Stones.
The next program's not a grant program.
It doesn't give out money, but rather provides contract
resources or in-house resources to advance
compounds or biologics.
Basically anybody is eligible to apply, researchers in academia,
government, industry.
And there's kind of three main stages.
One would be the discovery stage. If you're still doing target
validation, hit to lead screening, that would be
discovery. The development program is once there's a lead
identified and you're going up through
the IND-enabling activities to IND, that's where you would apply.
And then there's also a clinical arm.
If you have IND and you're looking for
resources for clinical trials, we have the NCI
networks for clinical trials, and so you could apply there.
So, this is a competitive program that you have to
apply to. Again, it's not a grant, but rather a resource
program. And everything is really advanced in a
milestone-driven manner, so projects will go through
different phases of whether they continue or not.
And currently, submission deadlines are just on an ad hoc
basis. And I put the contact information for
program managers if you're interested in learning more or
when those next deadlines will be.
This is just to emphasize that there are flexible entry
points for the next pipeline, and they can advance
all the way through from discovery to the more development stage
based on go, no go criteria, and
can eventually get to clinical trials if you go through the entire
pipeline.
Just to compare, since I've introduced a couple different programs,
the next program, which I just talked about,
is a real full
program for drug discovery, development, and clinical
evaluation. These are large projects, milestone driven.
You need to apply and
get peer reviewed by NCI for
this resource. It is resources, not grant money that's given
out.
And anything that's intellectual property brought into the program is
retained by the investigators.
Stepping Stones, on the other hand, it's really focused on our active grant
portfolio and NCI grantees.
We have limited this to a small molecule focus at this
time, and really it's limited gap-filling studies that may make you more
competitive for things like NExT or SBIR.
These are prioritized within a program
based on feasibility and need, and
just like NExT, it provides resources, not money for the
studies.
But you also retain any IP brought into the program.
And with that, I'll turn it over to Sundar.
Good afternoon, everyone. Thank you for attending this session.
I'll shift gears a little bit and talk about funding opportunities
for academic researchers, as well as companies who
do apply for some of the grant opportunities at NCI,
as well as some grant writing strategies for new and
early-stage investigators.
I have no financial relationships to disclose.
So as an overview, I'll provide the different types of funding
mechanisms NCI supports,
and the ways to identify funding opportunities, connecting with a program officer
or a program director
in writing better grants, as well as general guidance and useful
tips for new investigators.
So this table kind of has some of the
major mechanisms we fund through my branch as well as through NCI.
The R01 is usually the largest
fraction of the grants we fund. About 60% of NCI-funded grants
fall into this category. These are projects which are large projects
where you need a lot of preliminary data.
You can apply for grants up to five years.
The modular grants are equal to about $250,000 in
direct costs per year. If you're writing something higher,
it would be more than $250,000 a year, and they are called non-modular, and there's
usually an administrative cut for both of them.
And the key features of these
grants are you need to have decent preliminary data.
The R21 are smaller in scope, and you are looking at exploratory
research as well as data collection, and they are much smaller,
budget-wise, they are smaller. And R03s are even smaller, where you
get $100,000, $50,000 a year, and where your
primary focus is to collect data so that you can apply for an R01
later.
R15 grants are for specific institutions which
need resources where they can improve their research
environment as well as research of training of
students in their respective institutions.
There are other examples which we can go further later, but you can always
look them up at the NIH website. We have K99, which
are training grants. P01s are much larger than
R01s, where a group of investigators get together and write a program project
grant. And R33 is more like milestone-driven
R21/R33 grants.
So the funding opportunities usually fall into three major categories.
The parent announcements are investigator-initiated
grants where pretty much NIH has a single announcement
where you have a great idea, you write an application, whether it's an R21
or an R03 or an R01. You write.
It can be on any topic as long as it is within the
mission of NIH. And there's no money set aside.
It's based on amount of money. Each institute
has its own budget, and it's based on the amount of money they allocate
for these parent announcements. And these are
reviewed by standing study sections run by the Center for Scientific
Review. And the award is usually based on scientific
merit as well as NIH, as well as IC priorities.
Then the request for applications are
contrasts on the right side here is like these are NIH or IC-requested
research where they define an area, and these are
reviewed by special review panels, and there's set aside money.
So they set aside anywhere from 5 million to 200 million, depending on
the scope of the whole
announcement, and
they will have a set up, a special emphasis
panel, and they will award based on the amount
of money available for the RFA, as well as scientific merit, as well as
IC priorities. The center one here is like
program announcements. These are often broadly defined
areas. Once again, awards are based on scientific merit,
and sometimes they have special reviews.
But NCI is moving away from the center model,
where we are going to have
highlighted topics because
in order to
streamline the process, we are going to have highlighted topics which are much
more nimble, and they can be released within a few months so that
PIs can actually focus on research which are highlighted in
specific areas. And you will hear more about these
later as the
fiscal year moves on. And one of my colleagues, Jiang Xie, he's going to
be
in the NCI booth on Monday 21st, and he would be able to
give you some information. I think he's
going to be there from 1:30 to 2:30 PM.
So
you can always come to the NCI booth to get additional information on highlighted
topics.
So how do you identify funding opportunities?
Most of you can
know this already. I think it's a matter of going to the NIH
website, and you can look for specific funding
opportunities.
And you can also, depending on the funding opportunities, you can get
additional information about the funding opportunities using
the information on the scientific contact listed at the end of the funding
opportunity. So usually pretty much most funding opportunities have a
scientific research contact who will provide you some additional
information on specific
criteria being asked for each funding
opportunities.
So
one of the important resources one can find at NIH as well
as at every institute is our program
officials.
You can find them at, as I told earlier inIn
the funding opportunity itself, or you can find a matchmaker tool, which
you can find it in the NIH website.
You can email this funding of a program official
and get some information,
and set up a call so that you could get some additional information about the
funding opportunities. And most of the time, I highly recommend you to
email
your specific aims to a program official so that they can look at
it and provide you some
useful guidance. These are important resources within NIH.
And why do you want to contact them?
Because program officials listen to more than hundreds of
reviews every year, so they know what study sections are looking
for. They
can look at your specific aim and provide information and guidance on whether it is
feasible for an R21 versus R01. We always find
PIs writing a huge R01 but asking for two
years of funding. Sometimes it's the other way around, where you need to have
more preliminary data for an R01 compared to an R21.
Now, once you have a good idea, when do you want to contact them?
When you have a good idea, you can always
email a program officer and ask them whether it is feasible
for a specific mechanism.
And it's okay to write, ask program
official, contact them before you write an
application. But you need to have some idea there.
Then of course, program officers are the major point of contact
after your grant application is reviewed.
They review the summary statement, and they can provide
guidance on how to improve the next submission if it is not going to
be funded based on the scores.
So you can go to the NIH website, you can find the matchmaker
tool. It's basically, you cut and paste your abstract, and it
will find the program officials who kind of manage such
grants. For example, if your research is on the basic aspects of
cancer, cancer biology and so forth, it will most
probably pick a program official from the Division of Cancer Biology.
If it is more translational or preclinical therapeutics, it
will pick somebody in my branch or in our division who
focus on biomarkers, as well as therapeutics, as well as
clinical development projects.
So this slide gives
you some basic idea on general grant writing
strategies. So basically, you need to have a strong premise and a
scientific rationale for writing a successful application.
You want to emphasize on the cancer subtypes, types of cancer you're
working on. You want to have a molecular basis for studying a specific
target. You just can't pick a target and say you're going to work on five
different cancers. And choice of models is very important because
there is a new emphasis at the
NIH level where you want to have clinically relevant models to
work upon. Just because you have a mouse model doesn't mean you have to use it.
If there are better models out there, like organoids or
patient-derived models, it's always better to use
them. And always it's a good idea to have a
statistician look at your grant so that you are
having the right power calculations.
And you should always have a thoughtful discussion on pitfalls, as
well as alternative sections in your grant.
So what if
research experimental approach is not going to work?
What are the alternatives you're going to do, and what are the potential
weaknesses in your approach?
And a lot of
PIs kind of confuse innovation to high level
'omics analysis. You should always have a
clear analysis plan if you are proposing a
lot of 'omics type research in your application.
So you want to have
data analysis
descriptions as well as
information on how the data will be used.
And it's always a good idea to provide a timeline so that reviewers can look
at your application, see that you have done a good faith attempt
to see how each aim is going to be done over a period of five years or two
years.
For new applicants, it's always a good idea to contact the program official earlier
in the process. Seek input from senior colleagues
within your institution, because pretty much most institutions have
ways for junior faculty to contact and
get some help from writing better grants.
And it's always a good idea to write one application per review cycle.
As we see,
some applicants write multiple grants, and it becomes a
problem when some of these grants end up in the same study section, and
it's always better to have the best idea put forward,
so that you can focus on one. And it's okay to write a second idea.
If you have a second idea, it's okay to write, but don't try to cram everything
into a single cycle. And then if you have co-investigators
in your application, it's always a good idea for them to read and provide feedback.
Sometimes the letter of support or some of the information you are going
to use using a co-investigator may
have a fatal
problem where one of you might have overlooked that
problem. And it's always for new investigators, it's always good to have important
manuscripts published so that reviewers have
faith that what your hypothesis-driven research is,
has been peer reviewed and published by
you.So there are also multiple online
resources. The Center for Scientific Review has a lot of
information,
links for new applicants. And then if you want to become an early
career reviewer, you can also contact CSR.
This is another way to get an idea of how your application
is reviewed by study section. So if you are a new
investigator without any funding, CSR has a
pathway where you
are assigned a couple of
applications to review, and you get a chance to see how review panels
look at application and what they are looking for.
That's end of my talk, and I'm going to ask Dr.
Yali Fu who will provide information on the new simplified review framework.
Thank you, Sundar. My name is Yali Fu.
I've been
in this program for more than 30 years.
So today I'll give you a brief update on what has
been happening in rapid speed at NIH and at
NCI in terms of peer review and
funding strategies.
I have no financial
conflict to disclose.
So here is the life cycle of a NIH grant
application. First, like Sundar just
described, you have this great idea.
You have
prepared the preliminary data and consulted the senior
investigator and got everything ready.
You send it to the NIH.
So it's either
you can submit a new grant application or resubmission
or what we call a competitive renewal.
It's an established program that had been
funded in
repeated cycles. So your grant application goes to
what is called a Center for Scientific Review.
Its designation is like a institute
level organization,
and it's not NCI. Okay? So a lot
of early investigators get confused.
What is the Center for Scientific Review?
And where are your program staff? Where
this panel? We are not at the Center of Scientific Review.
We are the NCI. So the grant application goes to the
central referral
center at NIH, and then it's reviewed
by a scientific peer panel, consists of
investigators from extramural community.
This can be professors
or
researchers from independent companies.
And the scientific review officer is in charge of this
meeting. And this individual works for the
Center for Scientific
Review. Okay?
So after the peer review panel, the scientists
evaluate and give you a score with regard to the
scientific merit of your application.
After the review, they write a written
critique of what we call summary statement,
where the merit
of the application is scored.
And then it goes to me, goes to us, what we
call program officer at each individual institute.
Okay? So before the application, if you have any
questions, it goes to the scientific review officer,
SRO. Post the review,
you have any questions, it comes to PO, program
officer, okay, such as myself. So that is
your main contact. A lot of people get confused with
who is who, and it's understandable, but once you get used to it,
it's fine.
So
once you get the score
at the NCI, you go to another institute as well.
You go to the secondary review, which is by our
advisory council. In the NCI, it's called National Cancer
Advisory Board, which is a president-appointed panel.
They meet three, four times per year,
and they will
assess the program and approve applications based on
NCI priorities.
Once that is done, now the funding is based on
scientific merit and NIH and also NCI
priorities. As some of you know, in the past,
NCI has a pay line. We have worked with this pay line for many, many
years. And later last year, we have this
uniformed funding strategy at the entire
NIH where the pay line is removed. So
now we are looking at multiple factors, and most importantly,
it's the institute priorities. However, peer review, as
NCI director had said to the National Cancer
Advisory panel in the open meeting,
that peer review remains the cornerstone, the
gold standard for evaluating a project's
scientific merit, and we highly respect that.
So we will move from there.
So this new review process, it's in
effect
since January 2025. The structure
of the format of the application is not
changed.But the guidance to
the reviewers have changed because now I will talk
about the review criteria. The
overall impact score is not changed.
We changed from five scoring criteria, now
moved to three factors, what we call factor one, factor
two,
and factor three. Okay? The factor three
is not scored. Only factor one and factor two
are scored. Some of you, if you have applied during the
past few months, you have seen the change in the summary
statement. So what are the five criteria that we
have used for so many years? It's significance,
investigator,
innovation, approach,
environment. It has been in this order, and all these
were scored in the past. And now the new review
factors merged significance and
innovation into factor one.
So this basically asks us, so this be
done, why do we do this?
And then the investigator as their approach.
Their approach
becomes rigor and feasibility, and this has become
factor two, and this is scored. This means, can
it be done? Is the preliminary data worthy
of moving forward?
And then the investigator and
environment are somewhat de-emphasized.
In the past, you can say, "Oh, this professor has a
track record. She
or he leads this field or achieved a
lot." Those
credentials are de-emphasized. Now we see,
does this project propose appropriate expertise?
As long as it's deemed appropriate, the past record
is not mentioned in the review, and it's not a scoring
criteria anymore.
So other review criterias
that can affect the score is human subject
protection,
vertebrate animal protection, NIH take this very seriously.
A lot of investigators think these are just
administrative issues. No.
NIH as a whole
protect human subject. This is a huge issue about privacy,
whether it's justified to use human sample or human
participation, and the vertebrate animal now is also
emphasized. You need to be justified.
If it's a resubmission, then
it is being looked at whether you are responsive to the prior
critique. Have you addressed all the prior
concerns, or you just put in the same application again?
If you do that, if you are nonchalant with
the reviewer's comments,
that can impact negatively when this reviewer or the panel
sees the application again. So
other
revised consideration that won't affect your score is
authentication of biological and chemical
resources, and period of support.
And foreign collaborations, I'll discuss
next. Select agents, these are biologics and toxins,
if you have the proper
credential or the proper justification using this.
And resource sharing plan. Data management and storage plan,
it's a new requirement that's reviewed by
staff, not a scoring criteria, and needs to be
thorough and satisfactory before funding can be
released.
So with regard to the foreign
component, this is brand new and is a big
change at the NIH.
As NIH director has repeatedly said to the public,
NIH is committed
to foster and continue international
collaboration. And in cancer research, as we
hear today within 24 hours of the
symposium, there are so many good science coming out
from all over the world. So continue the collaboration is
extremely important to advance cancer research.
However, in the past, NIH has not
monitored how much funds
were allocated to foreign organizations
and institutions, either as an independent grant
or as a subaward embedded in a
US-funded investigator's grants.
So moving forward, starting last year, we
added
a new mechanism to carefully
monitor how much foreign support we provided.
Okay? So this new rule does not apply
to simple consultancy collaborations where no money
goes to a foreign organization. So a new code,
as opposed to R1, R21, a new code, PF1,
is assigned. Okay?
So this will be peer-reviewed. You need to write the foreign component.
If you have two or three foreign components, you need to write them separately.
And then afterwards, the applications are scored,
and then if it's being considered for funding, it
will be reviewed internally to have two parts.
First is the US entity, and then the second
is the foreign component. You can learn more about
this in the NCI
NIH announcement. So the bottom line of this
complicationof the change. We don't like change.
Nobody likes change. But moving forward, we need to learn
and adapt to these new policies. So
by doing
some homework, looking at NIH announcement, contact your
sponsor research office at your institution level.
They should provide you with some guidance.
If you have any questions, always contact the program
staff first before you just send in an
application.
Okay?
So
this is about what I
have. I want to emphasize one point that Sundar just mentioned
with regard to when to contact program.
Frequently, I get contacted the minute you get your score, and
you are anxious to know, "Oh, am I going to be funded?
What I'm going to do next?" Don't panic.
I understand this anxiety.
Always wait when you have the summary statement to contact
us to schedule a meeting to discuss how to move forward.
If you contact us before you get the summary statements,
the meeting won't be productive. Right?
Once you have the summary statement, you review that calmly, and you realize
where the weakness is, and you want to talk about it, we schedule a
phone call, a Zoom meeting to go over line by line
how you can improve the application.
But always do it after you get a summary statement, okay?
So this tip, I think it's important for established
investigators, too.
So, it saves everybody time. Okay. Thank you very much.
I think these are live. We're ready
for questions. I was told that you need to speak into the microphone so that those
who are
observing online can hear what you're asking.
If anybody has any questions.
I have a question for Yoli.
Yeah.
Thank you so much. That was great.
Several of my colleagues, they got two
percentile, but their grants are not funded yet for the past six,
seven months, and what not. They just want to know what's going on.
Us too.
We are-- Am I on this?
Yes.
Yes. Yeah, I understand. We are going through a transitional period,
but things are picking up pace. And so in the
beginning, we were waiting for some budget and how the procedure is
being established. So, moving forward, things are
happening as we speak.
We are moving full speed forward. Now we are
working already on the most recent reviewed,
the May council applications. So
don't worry, you'll hear from us soon.
I'd like to add one more thing. You have to realize the government was shut down
for almost 45 days, October 1st. The fiscal year for NIH
starts on October 1st, so it's 45 days.
Then we got the budget in January, the actual appropriated budget.
So it's a little bit more...
There's a lot of things which were out of our control.
So that's the reason things are moving slowly.
And we have lost staff, and they have changed the rules.
So everyone is trying to catch up.
My question was for Morgan about the Stepping Stones program.
It's for people with a NCI grant.
It needs to be a drug discovery grant, related to the
specific compound, or could it be a grant that's
funding related work but not about a specific compound?
If it's funding the target and you're doing mechanism,
but you, through some other means, have a compound,
like a lead molecule that you've identified, and
your grant is more
for the mechanisms or something, then usually we can still support it.
But it's a nuanced conversation that we'd have to have during
the consultation to see how close it is and whether it's appropriate,
but it's possible.
And then, yeah, follow up for the next program.
That is an application from the academic center, or can it be from
a spin-out startup?
Yeah. So for Next, you can apply from
SBIR or-- Sorry, from any kind of business or
from academics. So it doesn't matter. Anybody's eligible.
Thanks.
Thank you for great
presentation. So I have two quick questions.
So regarding Stepping Stone program,
if the institution have the comprehensive cancer
center status,
is that qualified if we are member
for that without a specific individual
grant?
So just being a designated cancer center probably wouldn't
apply. We do look for compounds or targets
that are supported by a grant. But for Next, you could apply
for support,
and at any stage. So that one would be appropriate.
Just for Stepping Stones, we do have to limit programs.
Second question is, I heard the Stepping Stone grant
is only for NCI grantee, but other
system or other service, are there any restriction?
I mean, I heard a lot of
service for everybody, but are there any
other service are restricted for NCI
grantee only?
None of them are restricted for
grant status, like the NCI-60 screen,
or the repositories. But I believe it's still in effect
thatIt's domestic only, I think.
For those, yeah. For our screening, it has to be domestic.
So you just have to be US-based institutions, yeah.
And for the
next program, it has to be a cancer therapy, but you
don't have to have grant funding for your private program.
And then for the things in the repository, you
can request as well without the active grant. Yeah.
Yeah. Those are open to any domestic-
Yeah
... investigator.
Okay.
Thank you so much for all the presentation, and I have a few questions
about
the presentation. First, regarding the Stepping
Stone, and
you define the small molecule.
How you define the small molecules, is based on the molecular weight?
This is very important for us because
we are working on a lead diagnostic drug.
The molecular weight is about
less than 3,000 Dalton. So can you consider this as
a
molecule or as nanoparticles? How you define it?
So usually we base it based on FDA, whether FDA would say it
goes to their small molecules or whether it would go to their
biologics.
We do handle peptides that are larger, PROTACs that are larger.
So, it's not like a 1,000
Dalton cutoff or something. It really is
based on
the compound and the
expertise for-
If you have a
drug conjugate with a polymer-
Mm-hmm
... conjugate as a delivery vehicle, then
yeah, it can still be considered a small molecule.
If you have pegylation and you have this copolymer-
Uh-huh
... attached to the active drug,
it's still small molecule because it's not biologics.
Okay.
Yeah. It's not defined by molecular weight.
Okay, great. Thank you.
Yeah, if you have any doubts, just contact us. Yeah.
Okay.
I also have a question regarding the Stepping Stone
and the next program is for the awardee, right?
We do have a
STTR, SBIR grant. And the question is, for those program,
should the
award have to be activate,
or it's past a couple of years, we still
qualify for the applications?
So they have to be active or a no-cost extension for
stepping stones.
Okay. But for the next-
But for next, anyone can apply. They don't need a grant or anything
associated with. It's just open to anybody and any compound.
Okay.
Yeah.
Thank you. The therapeutic drug,
do you consider diagnostic drug also?
So how you define it really therapeutic?
We have the drug for the earlier detection or precise
detection of the cancer.
So,
there are, I think, some theranostics that might
be considered as a therapeutic. But if the FDA considers it a
diagnostic, then it would not be considered by us a
therapeutic.
Come to think of it, I'm not sure that NEXT has ever developed a diagnostic, have
we?
Companion diagnostics.
Have we?
I've seen companion diagnostics.
In the NEXT program?
Companion diagnostics.
Yeah. I think it would be good to have a conversation apart from here.
Okay.
And we can see. The NEXT program theoretically is open to anything that
is helping
diagnose and treat cancer. So we could talk about it.
Okay, great. One more questions.
Sure.
When we submit a proposal that's for Dr.
Fu, and sometimes we were asked to provide the
institute, NCI could be one, the other one could be like
NIBIB. But these two institute have two
different duration time. NIBIB usually consider four
years, and NCI has
five years.
Mm.
And the situation, if it's switched to the NIBIB, then
my five
years budget, how are you going to handle this kind of
difference in term of the duration
time and the budget?
Well-
Because we cannot decide where we propose eventually will be assigned.
Well, yeah. Before you
apply, you should look at the, or contact me
or NIBIB program director that's in this field,
in nanoparticle, et cetera,
nanotechnologies.
We have
some overlap, but not recent years.
In the beginning when NIBIB was first established, there were a lot
of overlaps because they were trying to define
their sphere of
grants and science, while we
have already established area. So now,
we didn't have any assignment conflict with them anymore.
So when your grant application comes, if it's platform
development that can be applied to multiple
diseases,
it's not cancer-focused. If you have a specific aim
looking at a particular type of cancer, looking at
animal models and cell lines, they won't take it.
Even though your first aim may be modifying or
optimizing your nanoparticle
competition, your platform, it will come to NCI.
So that is pretty clear. If you have doubts, before you formulate a
budget, if you have abstract written, you say, "Okay, this is what I'm going to do.
My collaborator and my mouth PI,
this is what we are going to do." Then you should send
To me or to them to evaluate it, where it's best suited,
then you work on your budget.
I see.
Okay? So
first of all, it's the science, the
merit, right? Then we talk about the...
I understand that in the past, we have different pay
lines, so some investigators play. Where should I go? I go there.
I have a better chance to be funded, and I don't want to be at NCI, but your
science is NCI. They don't want it.
Even you want to go there, they don't want you.
So,
it doesn't fit their mission.
Thank you.
So,
that's-
Yali?
Yeah.
Thank you. If you need a longer conversation, we can carry it on afterwards, but
there's still three people, and we only have five minutes left.
Okay.
Sorry, sir. We only have-
No. No problem. Thank you so much. I really appreciate it.
Thank you. We'll be available afterwards to talk more, for sure.
All right. Thank you. It was a great session there.
I have a question regarding acquire PDX tumor
models, related products from NCI.
Can you get closer? I'm having a hard time hearing you.
Okay.
There you go.
Yep. So, I have a question about acquiring those kind of PDX
tumor model or related cell line or those.
Mm-hmm.
What is the waiting time
to apply? Like when was-
There's no waiting time. You can just go online.
There's whole online
directions about how to apply to get them.
There is a small fee that helps cover shipping.
And I forgot to mention that in addition to those models,
all of the
genetic characterization is online as well, as well as the pathology.
Pictures of the
tissues that it was collected from, as well as the disease,
the patient characteristics that it was collected from.
So there's all kinds of information at the PDM website.
Okay.
Okay?
Do you have restrictions how many
models you can require or...?
That is a good question. I'm not sure.
I know that we have priced it to be painful enough that you don't want
to...
Because they are difficult to grow.
Each one comes with its own recipe for media that you should...
and directions about how to grow it.
Sometimes investigators don't pay attention to that.
And so, we priced it so that you're not just ordering,
and not paying attention to the special needs of the
model. So I'm really not sure what the limits are, to be honest.
Yeah.
All right. Thank you. I'll look into there.
Sure.
Yeah. I have a
question regarding the grants
funding situation again. So, like the earlier person said
that this is 2% over there, I also have a couple of,
including myself and the other ones who get a score pretty good,
in 2025. But then the,
initially program officer would say, "Oh, maybe just wait
until
2025 has passed." Then he eventually
says
resubmission or not a resubmission.
Resubmission, you probably get a worse score possibly.
So it's just become a catch-22 situations.
What you advise on that?
Somebody get a 4 percentile, that kind of situation.
Yeah. 2025 last cycle was a anomaly because
there was a situation where we were asked by the government to fund
applications. Multi-year funding was imposed on us,
so we had to reduce the pay line on the last
cycle. So that's a kind of an anomaly.
It was out of our control. So the one lead thing we had to
ask PIs was like, "So unfortunately, you have to reapply and resubmit
as either a new application or
revised." If it is an 01, you have to revise.
But many folks were in the same boat-
Yeah
... where we were unable to fund them mainly because we ran out of money.
So
that has not happened in the past, but...
Yeah, that was the first year that we know of that they actually reduced the pay
line within the fiscal year, and it did
mess with the accounting as well as doing the multi-year funding.
So, it was difficult.
Yeah, so the information I got from program office is,
he doesn't know the answer to the question.
I'm sorry.
Thank you.
You're not alone.
Hi.
So we have a small molecule which is in clinical trial.
I'm a medicinal chemist. I developed over 170
analogs and using NCI 60
for top analogs. And now we
are working on the second
generation of
this compound. So we have two compounds,
based on those SAR that we want to
investigate for pre-clinical. So this research is
supported by DoD.
So what is the next step for me to use NCI
drug development resources for these two compound?
Sure. So, you would be eligible for the next program.
We do have, as Morgan mentioned, there's three
buckets, and the first bucket is discovery.
And so they would help you to... It depends on how much
data you have. I would say the very first thing to do would be to ask for a
consultation because we could tell you where it would fit.
But if you have enough data that you think it might be a lead
molecule to go into IND-enabling work or preclinical
development, then you could apply to that middle development portion versus
the... Discovery can be used to, if it needs more SAR, if
there's some unexpected toxicities
or not favorable PK, then the discovery
portion can do more refinement of that lead candidate.
But if you think you have a lead candidate and you have enough data to support it,
then you can apply to the development stage.
But certainly go online and request a consultation.
Happy to talk to you and explain it more.
Thank you so much.
Sure.
Sorry.
No worries.
I just ask one more question. So we do
identify the lead product,
but in the critical model,
and we want to push it to the IND filing.
I think the challenging we are facing is
how to discuss with FDA. We are funded by NCI,
we got the milestone we promised,
and now what are we going to push forward?
That is the biggest challenging we are encounter right now.
Mm.
So are there any resource can help us to
connect with FDA so that we know what
they are looking for and what we propose they
approve?
So what I will say is, as you can imagine, we have a lot of
experience with
our products being developed and going to the FDA, and then being involved in
pre-IND meetings and things like that.
And while we can't actually tell you how you should approach the
FDA,
certainly a lot of companies or investigators hire consultants to help them.
We can give you the benefit of what we believe would be appropriate
for a pre-IND package, what kind of GLP tox you would...
Our pharmacologists and toxicologists can tell you what kind of tox data you might
need. Our biologists might be able to tell you what sorts of
efficacy data you might need to have.
The manufacturing folks can tell you what might
be feasible formulations or dose preparation, things like that.
And then we have clinical colleagues who can also
maybe discuss the clinical proposal.
Certainly, if you want to apply to NCI for entry into the
clinical networks, they would be talking to you about whether they would
be interested in a proposal to put your drug
into the clinical networks. Morgan, do you have something to add?
Yeah.
Consultation.
Yeah, I was just going to add. So you can request a consultation, and we can
evaluate it that way. Also, I wanted to mention that we
held a workshop a few years ago
that included components on
communicating with the FDA and having conversations with the
FDA, and so we can send you, or you could look on our website,
and we could send you those recordings,
so you can look back and
see all the information from those workshops.
And then the other thing is you can always request a pre-IND meeting with the
FDA. Usually, you want to go into those meetings
prepared, where you have your proposed
ideas, like, "I want to do a
rodent and dog model for tox,
28 days. Here's how I'm going to do it. Here's how I'm going to dose. Is that okay?
Is that sufficient?" And they'll respond, basically, to your-
Right
... proposal. So you want to go in with already kind of what you
think is necessary and ask them if that's sufficient
or not.
Great. Thank you.
Sure. Thank you. Thank you everybody for coming.
Thank you.